this time of year
my home
spend the weekend watching college
football
i'm assuming
streaming's a no-go
we wouldn't put an ariel on the roof
that is actor steven root in the hbo
series barry premiering its third season
tomorrow night the dark comedy stars
saturday night live alum bill hader is a
hitman turned aspiring actor and root
plays the man trying to lure him back
into a life of crime while you may not
recognize his name he has been part of
some very memorable moments in tv and
film our jamie wax met up with him in
los angeles to talk about his long and
multi-dimensional career
i don't think so uh-uh i'm gonna call
hank we're gonna set the whole thing up
you might know him from this
it's her or this that if they move my
desk one more time then then then i'm
quitting i'm going to quit but the fact
that all these roles jim hudson from
thrillers hudson galleries
leave me the irony of being a blind art
dealer isn't lost on me
what we do
here
at the future freedom summit to comedy i
have decided
to run for president of the united
states
don't even scratch the surface of the
remarkable career of steven root
[Music]
supports the argument that he just might
be the most versatile
and busiest character actor in hollywood
i am north appeal i am a water monger in
the workers district what do you think
being a character actor means character
actor is
is versatile i mean there's a lot of
people who come up through their tv and
film they do their strength which is one
thing and they're great at it but
they're not a lot of people who can can
do comedy and drama
and change their persona i'm really
lucky to be able to jump
those worlds i can do a broad comedy i
can do a very heavy heavy drama piece
just how well do you know sugar
what do you want to know i just want to
know your opinion of him in general but
i was sure about my five other weddings
too
don't please don't tell charles he only
he only knows about three
and i feel very blessed i'm able to jump
back and forth like that i would argue
that the reason you can do that is
because you go
to your core
except you have to realize character
actors steal from the best
that's what they do you're influenced by
everybody his influences got him into
shakespeare and eventually broadway you
have no improv in your background but
you are as strong an improvisational
character actor on on camera as any
human being working right now that was a
learned experience for me and it
terrified me for a long time to do that
until i relax and realize it's just a
character and whatever comes out
if you just become the character
whatever comes out is fine and what came
out of stephen root landed him in
culture changing projects
from news radio billionaire bachelor
candidate brought down by own reporter
to king of the hill no i feel bad i
couldn't help ricky across the line of
course to multiple acclaimed films with
the coen brothers how meaningful have
the coen brothers been to your career
everything you know
what can i do for mr french
the first time i i worked for joel and
ethan was on oh brother
it was comfortable because they were one
mind they had everything storyboarded
they had exactly what they wanted except
they let you play director and writer
mike judge also let root play it was in
judge's now revered movie office space
that rook created one of his most
memorable characters
i was doing king of the hill for mike
judge at that point and he said listen i
wrote this movie i we have to read it
for the fox execs said
you want to come read it with me okay
yeah sure
mike was going to read milton
and i'm great okay if we walk over he
went i just want to listen to it you
read it and he took me into a little
room showed me a pencil sketch of milton
with him as the voice
and he said do
do something you know like in that vein
so i took that
and
gave him a little lisp
and went farther than mike did with the
character but then they switched from
the swingline to the boston stapler but
i kept my swingline stapler because this
is actually
the real swingline prop this stapler we
had
four four four of them
two of them we burned up in the movie
mike took one and i stole this one
[Laughter]
and he continues to go farther with his
work esther nice to meet you something
on full display in the new season of
hbo's hit series barry which pits root
against co-creator bill hader
and for which root has received
universal acclaim but it all might have
gone a very different way
and the notes came back from hbo saying
we love what stephen did
but he's here where does he go
there's no place for him to go the
character had been written as so loud
boisterous shouty guy and bill said yeah
you're right where's he gonna go so
let's make him
bad uncle and that's where that came
from you're in a transitional phase
that's all
so we totally re-shot everything i did
in the pilot i mean they could have
gotten another actor at that point but
they said no steve do it and we did it
doing it led to multiple award
nominations and yet more opportunities
for root these
ramps weren't always here yeah there was
kind of rickety who continues to add on
to the beautiful home he bought years
ago with the funds from his first bona
fide commercial success okay but you
bought this in the second season of news
radio yeah when you knew it was time to
invest well you got to get in the game
somewhere and i figured the show would
last two three years something like that
it lasted five and
you know life keeps going on and this
past year he even got a full circle
career experience revisiting both the
bard and a coen brother in the multiple
oscar-nominated the tragedy of macbeth
who's there
and for steven rood the goal isn't so
much different than what he's been doing
his whole life it's just to showcase it
in a different light
when they're looking for
a character actor role as you and i have
described it you've got to be the first
call that people are making right i'm
lucky to have a a resume but i i think
what next for me would be okay let me
circulate probably to do some sort of a
lead
in film i think that's i'm ready to do
that
but i i like to concentrate on what i'm
doing and do the best job i could do in
that you're still that working actor
still a working actor still the goal
uh it's a goal that's uh
that's reachable for cbs saturday
morning jamie wax los angeles
absolutely love him in everything i've
seen him in and just surprises you with
each one with each character being so
different the range is incredible yeah
yeah totally incredible i first saw him
in trueblood he was phenomenal i mean
playing this scary character it was just
just just rich he's always he inhabits
the characters yeah well he does are you
doing your milton i need a statement
i love that he has one of those staples
yeah